[Music]  pixar's latest film luca is said to have  theaters in june  the first images which were released a  few days ago are definitely looking  pretty fancy and you get quite excited  about summer  con wise luca is about a little boy  who's about to have a long summer full  of beaches  ice cream and pasta naturally he doesn't  enjoy it all alone  as he is with his new best friend  alberto however  the two share a big secret as they  actually come from a far away  underwater world and are in fact quite  unattractive sea monsters as soon as  they enter the water  on land however they're  indistinguishable from normal humans  and so they try to make friends with  human girls over the summer  whether this succeeds so easily is of  course doubtful  in any case we are eager to see the next  coming-of-age film produced by pixar  luca hits theaters on june 18th 2021  [Music]  bye